[MUSIC PLAYING]
"Dear bald guy, I watched
your threading videos.
I spawned 100 threads to do my
work, and my app got slower.
You're a horrible person,
and you should feel bad.
#enumsmatter."
My name is Colt McAnlis,
and yes, technically you
can spawn hundreds of
threads for your app,
but as you guessed
it, that might not be
the best idea for performance.
See, cramming too many
threads into not enough CPUs
is an old problem, and for
decades now, thread scheduling
has solved this by
using various metrics
to determine which thread gets
the next slice of CPU time.
Basically every thread
is assigned a priority.
The scheduler then
gives preference
to threads that are more
important, balancing that
with the need to eventually
get all of its work done.
Now, priorities are assigned
in a couple of ways.
Firstly, Android
assigns thread priority
based on the life cycle
activity state of your app.
Active invisible
apps are assigned
to the foreground group,
where the rest are assigned
to the background group.
And threads in the foreground
group get about 90% to 95%
of total execution time for the
device, where the background
group only gets about 5% to 10%,
which of course makes sense.
I mean, visible
applications on the screen
should get more
processor allocation
than apps which aren't visible.
Hm.
Secondly, it's important to note
that when a thread is created,
by default it's given the same
priority and group memberships
as the spawning thread.
As such, it competes
on equal terms
for processor time allocation.
So if your UI thread spawns
20 other high priority work
threads, they will
all compete equally
for CPU resources,
which pretty much ruins
your chance of
getting all of your UI
work done in 16 milliseconds.
To fix this, you
should explicitly
set thread priority
for any threads
you create in your application.
This helps the system to
schedule competing threads
in the same control group.
On Android, this is
accomplished using
the handy
Process.setThreadPriority API.
Now, just to be
confusing, this function
takes an integer value
between negative 20
and 20 where a lower value
indicates a higher priority.
Technically
speaking, this number
is actually supposed
to represent
how friendly this thread
is with sharing its time,
so negative numbers
means it's more
hostile to sharing its time.
But whatever.
To make this a little
clearer, Android
has provided some named
values for you to work with.
These values are defined
by Android.OS.process
and can be used as base
states to work against.
Default, of course, is what your
threads are generally given.
In addition to that, there
is a couple quantized values
to help you increment or
decrement the priority
to get a little bit more
fine grained control.
For example, the
UI thread is always
assigned Priority Default,
and any threads it spawned
will also be given
that same value.
But in reality,
worker threads should
be lower priority,
which you can set
by adding Priority Default
and Priority Less Favorable.
This way you can control
which of your spawned threads
might be more or less
important than others.
And in truth, setting
these priorities
yourself can be cumbersome.
And that's why classes like
AsyncTask or IntentServices
do this on your behalf, so you
don't have to deal with it.
But if you're using
threading and not
using one of these fancy
primitives, then of course,
you'll have to set
priority yourself,
so keep an eye
out on that, which
is always the weird
thing about performance.
There's many ways
to do one thing,
which is why you should check
out the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns videos,
to get a better sense of all
the options you have, and don't
forget to join the Google+
community to ask questions
to other great developers.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]